we're very happy to welcome Brian Chesky
to Bloomberg thanks for being here Brian
Brown of course is the co-founder of
Airbnb everyone knows what Airbnb is
thank you for inviting me today so tell
me how big your company is at this point
how do you measure it and how big is it
really overall there's probably two ways
of metric we have about 1.7 million
homes around the world in 34,000 cities
in 191 countries that's all the major
countries were all these tougher North
Korea and Syria that includes Cuba which
we launched in April and we now have
2,500 homes so that's one metric the
other is just to get a sense of how big
it is every night and there's probably
the most important metric and a peak
night this past August we had 1 million
people from around the world coming from
180 countries in a single night staying
in an Airbnb home never before would
this have been possible for a million
people from 180 countries live together
of course nowadays it's a problem with
your growth strategy though is the more
you grow the more scrutiny is upon you
and you've got regulators potentially
knocking at your Airbnb door how are you
addressing this the fact that those
people renting out their homes are
simply not paying taxes well first of
all they are simply paying taxes we are
going city by city United States collect
remaining hotel tax we collect from a
hotel tax in San Francisco in Portland
what like hotel occupancy tax so the
saint's you're paying this they are
saying the same amount of taxes that a
Hilton would pay yes exactly and on top
of that they declare income tax because
we issue every host at 1099 we've been
doing this for about six or seven years
and we're going city by city so our
whole principle is we want a partner
with cities and the bigger we get we
know the more attention we draw from
regulators but I also think the bigger
we get the more regulars say air maybe
our partners to us and so we have
partnerships cities all over the country
and in fact all over the world we passed
a national housing law in France which
recognized Airbnb we passed the law in
United Kingdom and city by city I think
we're starting to see a lot of movement
I actually two days ago was in
Washington DC meaning with a number of
Senators educating them about our
business what I've learned is the more
people learn about rbb the more they
love Airbnb but it's also about us
going eyes wide open in City and knowing
that we have to enrich the cities we
serve and partner with them so talk
about a different form regular should be
on tax which is zoning right about
whether this is really zoned as a
residential property or a zone as a
commercial one guy how do you regulate
at all how many nights a year a given
residents could be let out our etiquette
principle is this we want to have build
great relationships and landlords and we
ask all of our hosts to follow comply
with the local laws and regulations and
be aboveboard with their landlords about
what they're doing and we're actually
starting to pilot some partnerships with
landlords and cities around the country
so that is really what we're focused on
from a city perspective it's really a
short-term rental so we want to make
sure we collect remote all taxes and we
want to make sure that city by city
there is a legitimization of this
activity if it's about partnerships why
are you fighting against prop F which
would limit the amount of nights people
can rent out their homes because I don't
think that is actually an affordable
housing idea in other words I've had
thousands of hosts that have come to me
saying if you limit me being able to
stay in my home to be able to rent my
air B&B for 75 nights a year which is
what prop F would do I will no longer be
able to keep this home they're also
saying this I can keep this home because
I can rent my in-law unit if with prop F
I can no longer at my in-law unit I
can't keep this home I agree with the
spirit which is that we want to be
regulated to regulate Airbnb is to
recognize the Airbnb but I just don't
think this is a sensible solution Mayor
Ed Lee come out against this Gavan
nuisance county guidances the Sanford
school Chronicle has come out against
prop F we talk about safety for a moment
David and I are parents and when I think
about the fact that people can simply
rent out their couch young people would
love to do that if I had a David as a
daughter in college and if I had a
college aged son which I will eventually
and they said great I can make a cool
hundred bucks tonight renting out my
couch where are you on safety strangers
sleeping on people's couches where's
your responsibility lie well first of
all most the business not people staying
in couches but it's part of your
business and it only takes one or two
disaster situations to really hurt your
brand we've had 60 million people use
Airbnb to give you an example
last year of the World Cup 600,000
people went to the World Cup one in five
of those people a hundred and twenty
thousand stayed in Airbnb we did not
have any major reported instance in the
World Cup the whole thing when we
started this company everyone said this
is gonna be crazy this is never gonna
work and I said why they said people
will never stay with strangers and I
said well what if there are no strangers
what if you got to virtually meet people
before you stay with them so you had an
identity I have an identity we do lots
of verification checks on people the
whole thing works on reputation we've
had over 30 million reviews left on
Airbnb properties around the world you
can leave these reviews we have a 200
450 person trusted safety team so I
think in many ways we not only do many
of the checks hotels do on guests but we
probably go in many ways further than
many of the hotels do last June I
believe it was you had a major infusion
of capital right 1.5 billion I think put
it like a twenty five point five billion
valuation where do you stand on cash on
capitalization at what point you need
more and where will you look for it we
are we have plenty of cash at this point
to pursue like our dreams and those
include expanding quite aggressively
around the world including in Asia and
China so that's really we're focused on
but we have plenty of capital and I
don't see a need for more capital
minutes oh no IPO right away no there's
no plans for an IPO next year next
couple years wo and how is China going
China's going incredible and its fastest
growing mark in the world is growing
about 700 percent year-over-year let's
talk about that valuation for a moment
it's clear given that valuation you've
got a lot of money that's come in the
door there is a lot of doubt not
specifically about Airbnb but about tech
valuations can you speak about Silicon
Valley your company and do you really
think you're worth that number well
ultimately it's up to the investor
decide if we're worth that number not us
I will tell you this there's a lot of
comparisons to the 2000 but calm bubble
I think the comparisons are totally
inappropriate yet because you didn't
have a lot of people on line back then
you have like 60 million people or
whatever it was online you have a couple
billion people online today those
companies did not have revenue as far as
I know most the companies of high values
and say actually have a revenue and many
companies are growing more than a
hundred percent year-over-year
valuations go up valuations go down the
markets gonna soften for sure in the
future I'm not an economist I'm not
gonna tell you when but you have
suddenly in industry industries we're in
five years you can have a business like
ours so you go from zero homes to nearly
2 million homes a million people a night
there's an enormous amount of equity
created on our platform but you should
beat the dot-com bubble to not enough
people being on the internet I
attributed comm bubble to huge
valuations in a market that was way too
early with come B's that didn't have a
revenue model or you can now have them
sorry I just have no the businesswoman
are you cash positive we're doing really
well we don't discuss the finances but I
can tell you we don't have a need to
raise more money so that should give you
a sense of you know you're profitable we
don't comment on profitability we're
doing really well who's your competition
at this point is our hotels existing
please you know the hotel's definitely
some of them do not all of them do admit
they all think you they think you're
their competition I think there's a
pretty big industry so people different
views ultimately I think our competition
is just people not traveling I mean you
know give you example 40% of travel
united states people stay at friends and
family this is one of the top use cases
for Airbnb people you know staying there
would be twice as long as hotels when
you stay an Airbnb used typically stay
outside the hotel district I think it's
a different use case and I would I keep
telling everyone in South hospitality
industry outside the hospitality
industry they can believe me or not it's
for us to win I don't think anyone else
has builders so there you have a friends
and family or his main competition it's
when someone like Barry Diller goes on
record this week which he did saying
tech valuations are based on nothing
does it keep you up at night no we're
having with Airbnb is to going great and
whether we succeed or fail isn't going
to be come from some private valuation
it's because whether or not our
community of guests and hosts around the
world love our business and if we
provide amazing experience to people
every single day then we're going to be
doing incredibly well and we're going
very fast saddling regulators is sort of
ubers biggest foe the amount of money
they have to spend courting winning over
this situation that they're in are you
going to be the next uber in terms of
the established industry hating you I
think that we are very different from
every other company I never loved
getting bucketed into other companies
every one of us is gonna set our own
path I think that one thing that many
people on the world will say is there of
me is a very collaborative company that
cities around the world say they like to
actually working with us and I don't see
us battling cities we are a company that
brings countries together literally like
the citizens they live together every
night if a country if a company brings
people into other people's homes you
don't want to be a brand that's fighting
to your safety question so we don't want
to be a company whose brand is fighting
cities we want to be a company whose
brand is partnering and working with
cities and I think many cities would say
that is our brand so go out 5 years yeah
where are you and where's your biggest
growth you mentioned China earlier I
mean how big a market can that be for
you one of your biggest up we have 1.7
million homes in Airbnb there are
somewhere between you know they're
upwards of over 10 million hotel rooms
and Airbnb I don't know how many homes
there will be but there's no reason
there can't be close to as many homes in
the world on Airbnb
I think five years from now my hope is
you can go to any city anywhere in the
world any block any neighborhood and
today those doors are locked to you
tomorrow they're open to you you could
have access to any place and truly feel
like you live in that city like local
have you told the president this you're
on the President's Council I would
definitely go for an Airbnb at the White
House I'm just saying you know I
actually was invited to the White House
because I was I worked with him on
entrepreneurship in Cuba and when I was
there I had made sure to mention one
thing to him and that was we need to get
the Lincoln Bedroom on Airbnb and he
said I need to check with Michelle but
he told me was a longshot and I said mom
we need a good service might have
something to say about that said there
was a chance he I think he was humoring
I'm not sure might be the time number
one in a million chance let's do a
chance
Brian thank you so much s key co-founder